alors quelles sont les tendances pour
les prénoms des tout-petits faut-il
chercher l'originalité à tout prix c'est
la question que nous allons poser à
notre invité est notre invité qui est
stéphanie rapoport bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous c'est vous qui signé
chaque année l'officiel des prénoms
alors pour 2008 et mclaren lui calé à
pour les filles lucas enzo matisse pour
les garçons franchement on a un peu
l'impression que ce sont les mêmes que
l'année dernière
vrai que les tendances entre l'année
dernière et cette année n'ont pas
énormément changé pour le trio de tête
mais il y a des autres tendances qui se
dessinent quand même on a des prénoms
irlandais breton en qui sont en train de
percer actuellement en vigueur étant
comme comme ryan nolan evans et chez les
filles on a beaucoup de prénoms ou qui
sont en train de monter comme dans l'île
où lou lou ann hulu d'un bon voilà la
tendance pour l'année prochaine ou les
années qui viennent
qu'est ce qui marche aussi on parle
beaucoup des prénoms rétro non oui les
prénoms rétro sont de mise cette année
dans le top 20 on constate que emma est
pas la tête du palmarès des prénoms
féminins mais il ya aussi lucie et zoé
qui sont dans le top 20 et puis non loin
derrière jeanne louise sont en train de
percer et si l'on va un petit peu plus
en arrière rose et lila sont pas
l'entrée leafs en français chez les
garçons louis et jules sont déjà
intégrés dans l'armée dans l'école à
nice prévoyant 1
il ya aussi un retour des prénoms
bibliques oui oui dans les zones et en
fait ça vient d'une volonté des parents
de remettre à la mode des prénoms qui
n'ont pas été utilisés depuis longtemps
et dans ces prénoms on se dégage des
tendances donc c'est vrai que dans les
années 90 e des prénoms comme léa ou
sarah était monté énormément et 7,7
pouces et à fafe a fait monter les
prénoms masculins bibliques comme adam
gabriel raphaël qui monte en flèche
actuellement ou encore nathan et noah
alors est-ce que le prénom donne très
certainement une idée à la fois d
origine mais aussi du milieu social de
l'enfant
oui c'est certain que des prénoms
classiques comme jeanne paul jean marie
donne une idée d'un milieu plus
classique que kevin jenifer ou jessica
qui sont plutôt des prénoms anglophones
de séries américaines donc évident
effectivement on peut voir une
connotation sociale alors est ce que ça
veut dire que si on a un prénom
classique on s'appelle arthur ou adrien
on a plus de chances de réussir dans la
vie que si on s'appelle johnny ou kevin
il est certain que sur les cv les
personnes qui regardent les cv vont peut
être avoir des stéréotypes
alors quels sont les prénoms qu'il ne
faut absolument pas donner à son enfant
si on veut être dans le coup alors ça
dépend ce qu'on veut si on veut un
prénom qui n'est pas du tout attribuer
on peut donner cunégonde ou lucide ou
généreux ou l' aventure comme prénom on
est sûr d'être très original puisque ça
fait des années que ces frais n'ont pas
été attribués mais sinon il ya des
prénoms qui sont désuets et qui sont en
même temps répandues comme gérard rené
ou robert qui sont à la fois très
répandu mais ils ont leur coopération
voilà mes donc du côté féminin on a
quand même sylvie qui est un prénom
assez assez jeune et qui pourtant est
très très peu attribué malgré le fait
qu'ils sont répondus à la haye ce qu'il
faut tenter l'originalité est ouvrier ou
est-ce que c'est risqué pour les enfants
alors ça peut être risqué dans la mesure
où un enfant qui a un prénom difficile à
prononcer peut être amené à épeler et
répété tout au long de sa vie
l'orthographe de son prénom
donc ça peut être difficile et certains
portent mal
ce fardeau l'arize ont besoin de se
sentir reconnus et je le vois bien avec
mon site meilleur prennant points comme
ce que j'ai des emails régulièrement de
gens qui me disent à mon prénom n'est
pas dans les ouvrages de référence ça
m'embête
merci à vous en tout cas stéphanie
rapoport stéphanie j'imagine que c'était
très à la mode quand vous êtes oui dans
les années 70 merci merci